-Hi! How are you?
-Hi. I'm fine.
-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-Just fine?
-What's that?
-Well, because I'm sick and ti--
I wish I could be
behind the desk.
Now, ever since
the days of social media,
now you go on a show,
I'm supposed to be funny.
That's all.
-Uh-huh.
-But now I have people who think
they're Tim Gunn, you know,
my Twitter followers.
They're wearing Jorts
and, like, cut-off,
you know, Ultimate Fighter
shirts, and they're like,
"Those are the same sneakers
you wore three months ago."
It's like, "Shut up."
[ Laughter ]
In the old days, you'd just --
-Do you feel
self-conscious about it?
-It just irritates me
that everybody can judge
your wardrobe that's not even
in the fashion industry.
-Okay.
-It's bad enough
we live in a world
where Fashion Week
is every month in New York,
but now you have idiots
all over the place going,
"Yeah, I saw the jacket."
Shut up. You don't know
what you're talking about.
-Not only do you look
presentable, you look very fit.
You look very healthy.
And these are all good things,
because since
the last time I saw you,
you had a heart attack.
-I had a heart attack.
And, you know --
No, here's what bothers me.
'Cause I've been
in the business 105 years.
[ Laughter ]
And I still have to tell people
I had a heart attack.
Just now,
the guy from TMZ downstairs.
I swear to God, walking in,
I go,
"Well, I had a heart attack."
"You had a heart attack?"
Even TMZ, I have to tell them.
[ Laughter ]
That's not fame the way
I always thought it would look.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
I'll tell you
a true but sad story.
These guys were bringing
a couch up a stoop
down by where I was,
and this guy recognized me.
Knew my name, 'cause I'm famous.
-Yeah.
-And he goes, "Colin Quinn,
grab the other end
for a second?"
He was serious.
He wanted me to help him
bring a couch up the steps.
You know, it's like, "Rihanna,
you got jumper cables?"
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, I had heart attack,
and -- you know, people --
I look at it, it's not the end.
It's the beginning of the end.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Because now
I know I'm gonna die.
Like, before this,
I figured I'd probably die.
-Uh-huh.
-You know, you figure,
but now I'm like, "Oh, no.
I'm really gonna be
one of those that dies."
[ Laughter ]
And the thing that bothers me
the most is -- two things.
One is, all my comedian friends,
you'd expect them to be original
and have, like, a take.
The same, tired clichés
that you people would say --
no offense.
[ Laughter ]
Crowd's like, "Heh. Hey."
Yeah, they're like,
"You were really lucky."
I'm like, "Yeah,
that was my lucky day.
I should've played
Powerball that day."
[ Laughter ]
That'll go down in history
as my lucky day
that I'll always think about.
And, um...
No, but it's like, I know how
people look at heart attacks.
Like, I always looked
at heart-attack people,
and I know people
look at me that way now,
which is, like,
"You're not dead,
but you're not a reliable
member of the planet."
[ Laughter ]
"You're not somebody that we're
gonna count on in the long run.
You know, give plans like
a month ahead, nut, you know...
'Cause it's, like,
you're on, like,
some kind of a warning track
or an on-deck circle.
You're not dead, 'cause
the most important thing in life
is survival, and you're not
great at that, basically.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause if I went out --
Like, if right now,
anybody in this audience
goes outside and dies
in the street, on 49th street,
it'll be a tragedy.
If I die, people will be like,
"That was sad.
He didn't have the heart,
though, You know?"
[ Laughter ]